tyler is in denver hi tyler how are you
hey can you hear me okay absolutely
what's up
great um hi i'm a huge fan of your show
i've watched almost all your clips on
youtube
i'm really excited to talk to you right
now got a bit of a career question for
you
um my name is my name's tyler i
graduated from college in 2019 in
engineering school
um i'm 24. i uh i work for an
engineering
company make about a little under 90 a
year and um
you say this oh thank you a lot of times
i hear you say this quote on the on
on youtube um you know it's bad to have
a mentality of oh
oh god it's monday thank god it's friday
kind of thing um and i just kind of
wanted to elaborate on that a little bit
um i would say i'm kind of in that boat
um i really enjoy where i work you know
i work with good people i think the
stuff i do is is technical and
interesting
but you know obviously if i had the
choice i i obviously
wouldn't work a nine to five at a desk
all day so i'm just wondering you know
is that a bad mentality to have how can
i get out of that or or what can i do
about these feelings
well let's just play this out you're 24
you've got an engineering degree the
work
interests you but you gave us a big clue
i don't want to sit at a desk all day
that's not wrong to feel that way but
let's look at what the future
what you want the future to be so let's
fast forward 34
44 what kind of work would you want to
be doing at this very moment what would
you say
yeah i mean i love what i do um you know
i love i love tech and i love
engineering and i'm a computer
programmer essentially
but um you know so i move up in those
ranks you know
start taking on project leads and and
stuff similar to that
but um but like i said you know it's
still a nine to five thing
um i think i'm conflicted more you know
the idea of like well
i'd rather be doing this or that you
know i'd rather be outside i'd rather be
you know with friends and stuff like
that
and i'm not saying obviously i don't
like my job because i do i i do
so you're all over the place so i want
you to say it just like you just don't
want to go to work yeah because outside
and be with outside with my friends
that's great but that's not work
what do you want to do i mean you
started to give us a clue there you up
the ladder
you're 24 first of all so you need to
relax you're in that entry
position uh and you're making almost 90
000
a year so you're in you're on the ladder
so what does the ladder look like what
do you want to be
doing at 34 44 do you want to work for
yourself have your own tech company
what is it i know you've allowed
yourself to think about it say it what
is it
sure um i mean i've never even really
considered the possibility
of starting something where i work for
myself i just kind of am under this
assumption that i'll be in some
some corporate structure okay forget
assumptions what are you
what do you wonder about when it's just
you what is the 45 year old you doing
professionally what have you allowed
yourself to imagine say it now let's
assuming you're
working at something yeah playing with
friends
like badminton in the backyard yeah
exactly
no i i you know i obviously i i enjoy
having a stable and steady income
um so that i don't want to change
obviously tyler um
you know what is the dream say it
say it i know you thought it i've done
this enough tell me what you dream about
what i dream about i mean i dream about
i i'm not going to be panicking here um
no no okay so here's
just moving up in it moving up all right
so moving up tell me what moving up
looks like what are you forget about job
title forget about how much money you're
making forget about how you get there
you're letting your brain run i want
your heart to answer this question
you love the work of engineering you
love that creative technical aspect to
what you do is that true or false
true okay then so if you want to keep
doing that kind of work
and moving up the ladder you need to
begin at 24 to go what does that ladder
look like
way up top start looking at that stop
focusing on well i'm at a desk eight
hours a day
well you're 24 man and paying dues for
you
is really good right now i mean you're
making almost 90
000 a year you're overthinking this
start to talk to engineers who have been
at this for 10 years
15 years 20 years what's the kind of
work you would love to do and if you
want to retire at 40
great there's nothing wrong with that i
mean are you supervising engineer
products in the field
in the field which gets you out of the
office in the future
uh no i work for a website company so
i'll be indoors most of the time no i'm
saying
you might not be working for the same
company dude yeah
yes got it got it if you're doing injury
what kind of engineer are you
i'm a computer engineer a computer
engineer okay
all right i had i had you engineering
buildings for a minute i'm sorry okay
um
okay so you know you've just got to
decide i don't know
of a situation i can't think of a
situation but i i'm not an expert on
your field
i've got about 300 of you working here
but none of them work outside
they all work in the building um and so
we don't have any
computers out in the amphitheater or the
park next door or around the fire pit
or the various places i mean i actually
have wi-fi out there you can go out
there and see it
but um yeah but uh a nice day but the
vast majority of them work inside the
building
so um yeah i think probably
what i would leave you with is this um a
there's nothing wrong with paying your
dues for a few years and sitting there
and while you're making 90 grand paying
your dues to ken's point is not bad
uh b and and so just plan on that b
it does not just because you do that for
two the next two years does
not mean you have to be doing that for
two decades
you get to choose i'll tell you one
thing that i know
one thousand percent chance over the
scope of my career
i'm one thousand percent chance your
world is going to change
computers are going to change i mean
when i
when i was your agent starting there
weren't computers
the personal computer was not very
personal
and so i mean back when the dinosaurs
roamed the earth it's hard to imagine
that but uh
feels like 20 minutes ago and then i've
watched the computer evolve
into these tiny little things in our
hands which will do more than
a whole building full of them would do
just a few decades ago so fast forward
your thing a few decades
uh you may be doing stuff from sitting
outside working on holograms i don't
know
something's going to be different yeah
and so and we're not picking on tyler a
lot of people get in this situation
dave this is what we do every day on the
ken coleman show people get a little bit
locked up
and so what we're pressing for is this
allow yourself to look out
and say what's the kind of work that i
think would fire my soul
up and at 24 you might not know that's
the reality
he's really young today you might my
point is with technology curve
today you might not see how you're quote
working outside
unquote uh doing your job but two years
from now
it might be going everybody's doing that
and here's what they're doing that's
exactly
i don't have any idea what's going to
happen but so the point is you are not
locked into this
for 40 years yeah there's no chance you
can't
do what you're doing for 40 years it
won't exist right it won't even exist
five years from now that's right
so start problem solving in your head as
an engineer as a computer technology he
really enjoys the work there are clues
there so if you want to work outside
allow your mind to wander a little bit
and then go do some research here's what
i mean what are some problems you want
to solve that are more outdoor in nature
maybe one day you've got your own
company
uh that is anywhere you're in the truck
and you're moving around you're going
from site to site who knows
but you've got to start to look into
that and you don't overthink the fact
that well i'm in this indoor job right
now
and i get it he's young but you've got
to allow yourself to explore some things
and listen to those clues if you like
being outdoors a lot all right then
well then how are you solving the type
of problems you like to solve and how do
you take that creative solving
and that technical solving ability and
go okay how can i do it out here
in this world and again not to pick on
him but it is a
normal thing in today's world
to go from high school to college
and your first job is you go to work
every day and you work all day
yeah and that's a new emotional
experience
that's exactly right because you've not
done that you know you
and so literally what is occurring is
you're developing a work ethic
that you've not had to have previously
it doesn't mean you were lazy before
but you're experiencing the emotional
bending of
i've got to have the discipline to go to
work and work while i'm
at work from nine to five and deliver
results so i can keep on working
amen i mean there's that's grown-up land
right there